hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the Council of Hanwell
now this is a newly released steam game
and it's pretty fleshed out as far as I
could tell
moderately decent reviews in my control
okay alright do I need to be on the
lookout for this guy who's extremely
swole I mean if there's just a big buff
dude who's grumbling a lot maybe he's
just angry
gotta get protein for the muscles I
suppose so I don't know a lot about this
game and I don't even know if it's gonna
be any sort of good but we're gonna find
out huh oh no okay where the hell am I
going and why am I going there did the
big buff guy smashed through these
bricks on the wall and it seemed to be
coming in more than they're coming out
okay I don't like it when games tell me
to run I really don't like it that's
just not appropriate okay this is weird
huh uh-huh
thanks for the tutorial on how to play
pretty much any game ever oh boy I sure
do love all these notes here well that
didn't sound good hmm okay muscle guy
[Music]
let's put him behind bars no padding the
damage he does to himself barely has an
effect anyway well that seems like a bit
of a problem is he gonna do that damage
to me if you can do this to a room what
is he gonna do my soft supple body Oh No
all right woo more Oh what is this hi
hello is that just random flickering or
no press Q to equip the radio the radio
mints a continuous audio playback one of
our anomalies are nearby hello anybody
[Music]
that's in the future okay so is that
what you did is that what happened to
buff dude he was on the way to the gym
and you're really jacked up his day I'm
he's probably happy about it if he
wasn't so incredibly angry hello I
didn't even notice this before oh I
don't want to do that oh that's not
looking behind me either Oh Oh what the
hell I don't know why it's so blink
Blanc E right in this hallway but it's
giving me a bad feeling of the
heebie-jeebies oh there we go
okay yeah that's that's incredibly
useful and I don't know why when I'm
looking behind me I just like to jostle
my head around like a bobbing puppet but
like a bobblehead
cognitive function [ __ ] that doesn't
seem like a good idea even if you were
trying to actually punish him cuz if
he's got enough muscle to pass through a
door I'd I think he can rip off some
staple okay whatever you know what I'll
think combat I didn't know if there was
gonna be combat in this game back with
LMB block with ride MB so it's like
vermin ty wall slow-motion and V oh well
can I have that again I I just went
through this I know okay slow motion it
is yeah alright so who am I gonna need
the ice pick in the forebrain does
someone need a lobotomy somewhere behind
me access the inventory with tab from
the inventory you can view and store
keys and use any items you possess for
the help with the inventory press H
whenever it is open okay Wow
disused maintenance key great why was it
dangling on a chain as if it was a trap
use e and cancel an action with qqs can
be stored enough that we'll use still
unlock doors there's a lot to take in
okay this is a lot oh there's a lot to
take in
okay alright okay fine flashlight oh boy
another tutorial over using the
flashlight will lead it to malfunction
and may cause it to break completely X
to switch between normal and ultraviolet
just go ahead and use it completely
alright hello anybody okay
would do with there's something nearby
you just gonna drop that knowledge on me
hello okay well tutorial over time to
really get the [ __ ] down the pipe
I suppose oh good I can see now
anything ultraviolet in here
surprisingly no I thought there'd at
least be blood and/or semen all over the
walls
oh okay alright wow it's real static in
here huh I don't know what that means
but okay alright but what the [ __ ]
hell oh my god what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you
what is that how do I switch the third
person the [ __ ]
okay well third person oh-ho look a big
dumb arms whoopin through the bird how
do I get okay there we go it's Z III I
panic hit the Z your weapon is worn out
and broke well there's the point of all
of that
alright then maybe I can use my
maintenance key add two key ring yes do
that I guess why wouldn't it
automatically be added to my key word
why do I have to it doesn't make any
sense and I don't like it but the
graphics are nice should I look behind
me how do I do it again I'm totally for
there we go oh yeah nothing's buying me
okay good
alright okay alright here we go alright
maybe I can stop being a little [ __ ]
for a little bit and try to actually
make some progress here anyone behind me
no okay good great I love it mmm stairs
oh your journey to the council once you
leave this area you will be taken
through six locations each containing a
piece of a citizenship card make your
way through east location find all six
pieces and finally uncover the secret to
some Hanwell [ __ ] that I think I saw
Oh
oh okay emerging from an old brick shed
I found a well-lit path leading to a
house
I will surely find clues about my
situation there I don't even know I'm
here
I don't even know what I'm doing okay
let's do this
ah I'm in aa boob lights my favorite
okay I'll just keep going as if I know
what I'm doing which I do as far as
you're concerned oh hello this is a
depressing magazine cover all right well
then is that the mayor is it's not my
house seems like it's not my house if I
just don't you think I would recognize
my house also that is really weird and
that is really dark
okay all right well then all blonde
perfect my favorite thing all righty
then what have we got here Daniel I I
left them I'm sorry I ripped the bottom
to see it clearly I can see it fine
Daniel I left the mayor's letter and our
final piece of Miller's card and the
safe I won't be able to get it to her so
you may have to if you forget the code
just remember it's always annex
what that doesn't help me at all you
dick all right fine am i Daniel or am I
just another rube that was drawn into
this my research assistant for whatever
the hell they're researching new
steroids for bodybuilders oh no huh
hello something tells me I shouldn't be
here something tells me I shouldn't be
invading these peoples lovely privacy
okay good good for me good good good
that's good
Oh
why is that glowing so my Sekulow why
why is that glowing perfect collect all
doctor DNA and which eyes oh yeah sure
okay doctor DNA which eyes everyone
knows it everyone loves it everyone
collects it and I don't want to be left
out none cool when I go back to school
and everyone's asking me where my doctor
DNA and which eyes are I guess I'll just
mosey on my way pockets a jingling with
a said thing oh okay okay all right you
want to tell me what this council is or
do I just have to guess oh wait it's
always a double you know it's always a
next all I do is win Oh
one two three four I get it ah all right
ha ha ha Oh easy might as well just give
me the code I suppose alrighty then what
did I get
oh dear mayor Lawson here's a piece of
Isabelle Miller's citizenship card you
may keep this as a reminder of what will
happen to you if you oppose me Oh nice
threat to open that with I split the
card into six pieces and distributed
them amongst Han Wells most prominent
citizens you're the last hand well
belongs to me regards the doctor all
right okay
it's quiet now all right Isabelle
Miller's card holders herself in jail
Sam Nicholls Church Taylor Walsh
hospital Walter young power plant
Brett chambers school
the mayor was the only class 1 citizen
in zone 3 without her card nobody can
access the council building what kind of
messed-up world is this I mean this is a
lovely house especially for a doctor but
it seems like the world is some kind of
Hunger Games [ __ ] going on and no
one no one's real oh no one's really
knowing what's going on okay all right
well I'll just get Adil back down
nothing's gonna happen to me guess I'll
just leave but I didn't see it I was
looking at a corner I didn't actually
see what happened who's there
my flashlight okay there we go aha and
we'll cancel the public protection
anomalies in your area prepare so this
is a regular oh that's my shadow I got
scared by my own shadow everybody okay
all right good to know well just gonna
mosey on to work time for me to
skedaddle on out of here I gotta hit
okay I gotta hit the dusty trail if you
want to get into the council and figure
out who the what's this doctor is doing
with me I'm gonna have to find all six
pieces of Isabel Millers citizenship
card there's apparently a piece in the
church all right
oh we're here all right lovely place I
like the decorations very jesusí it's
awesome okay find the piece of Isabel
Miller's citizenship card all right sure
is it actually in the church or do I
have to kill someone to take it from
them because that seems to do that seems
more likely of the cases okay okay not
that door I guess we're just not gonna
go there all right okay ah you know what
I'm gonna check the other door I'm in
like that seemed a little spooky well
okay I guess one with this door we don't
have a choice in the matter who you do
hello anybody here Oh notes thanks for
agreeing to help out with the ritual
it's such a cheerful start thanks for
helping out with the ritual sacrifice
got your knife ready oh we're gonna need
20 litres of goat blood lots of people
coming by today's hymns are extremely
important be sure to keep a note of them
before they're changed and never forget
a painting is worth a thousand words
that's just something I say at the end
of all my letters I'm a weirdo like that
alright whatever right okay yeah cuz
we're friends yeah so this is why I have
both doctor DNA and witch eyes cuz it's
just a half a dozen a16 or the other
we're just all equal measures oh boy why
am I here I'm here I pick all pictures
worth a thousand words huh oh it's
always an ex nope
a thousand oh the hymns that's right
okay alright the hymns must be the code
right ah okay how about I get six to
nine one let's try that whoa hi well how
convenient okay my other guess was going
to be the numbers that were missing
compared to one to the other that would
have been a clever puzzle okay I got it
okay you oh okay all right
well this is doctor DNA where's that
witch eyes oh I can never tell which oh
the kids at school are gonna really like
me now oh I think I got it I think I got
it if I didn't god
Thank You orchestra
I really appreciate whoever's on that
organ very timely I I really do
appreciate that okay let's see what
hellhole I'm getting myself into more
DNA Oh frabjous day
Callooh Callay I am so happy about this
situation what am i okay I wasn't ready
for that
help me hmm I can't read this U+ no no
help me okay was there something on the
back or something well no all right just
a random note that somebody left for me
to discover
okay hello open you know this is a weird
Church I'm just gonna gonna say oh oh oh
that's okay oh there's something
oh there's something oh okay well all
right then well this it seems a little
odd to have in a church but oh it's keep
I'm sorry Scott just take it
sorry okay all right I'm Audi
I'll see you little outlast esque always
good hmm
all right no anomalies gonna get in here
that's for not for damn sure
okay what am i what am I
doing here well I got a key good for me
so now what is there something here that
I need to unlock er is this literally
the only thing kind of room is this it's
a bunch it's like it's like a stadium
that people can just gather around and
watch Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
well is pleasant to listen to
what did I just pick up I have no idea
oh why did I come down here why did I
come down here oh ah oh sure
oh okay all right sure you telling me
this doesn't work this magical box that
I've put next to these wires doesn't
work all right okay where are you going
I'm on to something here
my detective nose is really telling me
something smart about this
oh oh
very obviously there oh whatever what
can you do oh boy oh these are big cards
did you see that thing was is like a
quarter of a pillowcase Oh leave the
church yeah okay all right you know what
I wanted to do that before and now you
know it just doesn't feel the same now
it does now feels like I'm being kicked
out it's not my choice oh well let's
leave the church I guess no no no no no
come on now
I'm a bee all right I'm a tea
nothing bad better happened on the way
out okay all right oh okay I guess it's
as easy as that
looks like the Mayor was pretty busy in
the final moments of the council's
operation she mentioned to school I
remember passing a school on the way to
the church I should go check it out you
know what I should Here I am
okay oh sorry
[Music]
okay all right
Wow I got I got I don't know why but I
just got sudden what did I pick up is
that a which I I got a winch I everybody
I got a winch I let me pull the fire
extinguisher in celebration wash out any
of these demons yeah I got it I got a
sudden flashback to dead space two in
the school there Oh super weird I have
no idea why
Oh DNA perfect whoo dude in my pocket I
guess I don't even know what that's for
okay not going in there all right well
just carry on everybody show your faces
what is that oh it's a light nevermind
it's a whole lot of nothing okay I'll
just keep going this way lot of Oh
[Music]
hate it hate it I hate it I hate it
already thank you I hate it
okay DNA in my pocket still locked
okay still lock nothing good here
nothing good for anybody and nobody's
happy about it okay welp turn that off
saving my power what I saw something you
can't tell me I didn't see something oh
good more DNA my favorite thing my
flashlight is gonna break on me at the
worst time isn't it well stuff that in
my pocket I'm pretty sure they were kept
in like like cooling chambers of some
sort and I'm just stuffing them in my
warm pants pockets can't be good for it
you know just something tells me it
ain't oh there we go
put it right next to my buttocks hmm
that's a good place for doctor DNA oh no
it's never a good thing oh it's never a
good thing when there's lockers never a
good thing
you know just judge but I thought
something was gonna happen this seemed
like the perfect opportunity to spook me
and and the fact that it didn't happen
makes me only more concern oh that's
I'm sorry I'm sorry for everything I've
done could you not oh hi okay if I turn
off my light and forget that you were
there are you still there all right well
that's a problem
what I did i swish nothing all right
well this is a conundrum all right well
I'll just sit no okay all right well I'm
coming for you that I can't run for some
reason or else I'd be chair charging
straight down your gullet hole okay this
is worst thing all right I'll give that
spook a solid b-minus yeah you're not
gonna get me batty oh I'm sorry I walked
into the wrong room I'm sorry I thought
this was my classroom is clearly for
something else uh yeah this seems much
more normal
maybe I don't like you okay more DNA I
know I gotta go back to that room but I
jumped it about it just didn't rub me
the right way you know very few things
rub me the right way and I don't think
that's one of them yeah still bad yes
still something very wrong about this
Oh something in the corner is that a
which I also Oh okay good good
you better not you sack of [ __ ] you
think you can mess with the likes or
didn't get me that time yeah where'd you
go do huh huh
y-yes right that's what I do i yeah
that's what I thought oh okay I don't
like that I don't like this room I don't
like that huh I'm out of here
see you never [ __ ] I'll be gone oh my
goodness
alright let's try going up cuz
apparently there's some reason that I
need to continue exploring this place
and not some reason that I need to run
screaming at the oh never mind
see that for some reason and my athletic
ability is just incapable of hurdling
over that all right what do we got on
stage here yeah this is what remind me
of dead space - oh man I love that stage
I love dead space to God oh there was
another one but it seems like that one's
gonna be dead forever this looks like a
trap looks like a trap okay not a trap
all right well that's good news for me
they keep lulling me into a false sense
of security it's good
[Music]
Oh demons go away okay wanna try going
upstairs here instead wait let me try
the back room now cycle back around I'll
go upstairs first and then I'll come
down hit the other side that seems like
a strategic way of killing everything
that I ever hoped and dreamed for okay
now you're gonna do it this time in my
pocket okay well you seem to be busy I'm
a busy guy
I'll just go right past you dude oh okay
all right well good didn't know that the
only thing you need to do to beat demons
back into the void is walk towards them
very slowly use their own weapon against
them that's what they do to you that's
what you got to do to them it makes so
much sense now I'm so smart what do we
have okay never mind completely farewell
and it's gone forever okay
something is coming possibly tonight
there's no advantage of teas staying in
the city to see this through the
children are safe
get out while you can okay the children
are safe I doubt this person got through
Hey look at which eye something tells me
I haven't gotten all those and I'm
probably not gonna get the quote-unquote
good ending if I don't but at this point
what's it matter what does it matter
demons are gonna consume my soul no
matter what I do
Oh more anything of the burger any
witches eise's no all right anyone
stuffed into lockers horribly
No all right well guess I'm not going in
there all right I wanted doop oh wait I
got to put it on my key ring that's
right I forgot about that okay I'm not
gonna do that I'm gonna try this see if
it opens uh-huh uh-huh
looks normal no diamond dollz but
there's some doctors DNA wait I just I
just connected the dots about something
is this legitimately the doctors DNA as
in the doctors very own sperm tell Craig
I felt all right sure yeah that's very
helpful thank you thank you for that
because if that is true then why in the
hell am i carrying it around with me Oh
how to tell if someone has been tainted
how to keep burners from entering a home
dealing with witches if disturbed the
meaning of life identifying and
reporting to what how to survive being
tainted what I saw the doctor this
morning I knew I'm evacuating the kids
tomorrow morning I guarantee you this
time tomorrow the mayor will be signing
a citywide evacuation order okay all
right I don't know what you okay you
know what maybe I just shouldn't
question anything maybe I should just
carry on to the next room like I'll tell
Craig that someone fancies
I'm on a mission okay oh oh I unlocked
it I don't like what was going on in
this school I'm gonna come out and say
it I do not like what was going on in
this school who you gonna come out of
there oh you little scamp
huh come on come on out okay it's okay
no one's gonna hurt you unless you hurt
someone namely me is the thing I'm
concerned most about I I can't get over
this school whatever am I going to do I
guess I'll have to go around oh no two
schools
my biggest weakness doubled I am a
helpless little baby okay let's continue
I can't expect every game to have pubget
style of hurdling mechanics ooh more DNA
this is the teachers lounge that's nice
I guess can I get some coffee
oh I see you okay well I got that
something did I go to have I been in
every room yet because if I have I swear
that I'm I'm missing something right
there's got to be something I'm missing
cuz I didn't get the card yet and I'm
pretty sure I bet everywhere all right
then
oh yeah it's a double hallway that's
right oh wait no that's wrong
okay well hmm still doesn't Oh oh it is
oh no I hate horror game bathrooms
they're the worst hello Craig are you in
there Craig Craig Craig Craig but hi
Craig someone fancies you
[Music]
Gregg come back please Oh which is I
perfect Gregg come on man restroom
etiquette I can't read it all right
great
Gregg don't run away from love
Oh girls Jenny Jenny oh there's some DNA
in this bathroom that's not good Jenny
Jenny Craig Craig didn't respond Greg
Greg's a douche you gotta leave him he's
not worth it oh okay all right then I I
suppose
what are we get in here anything all
right nothing nothing then what the hell
am I missing I've been everywhere right
I think I'm pretty sure I've been
everywhere I don't know where else I
could possibly go oh wait have I been
what is this door here just a mystery
door oh it's a storage closet oh yes
what am i what do I use this for we've
got a security a system do I have to
hack into here I don't know I don't know
ma'am but I don't like it oh my good at
all
oh here whoa how did I miss that
okay well I got that and that means that
is yes unlocks all the doors in the
school which is very handy because
there's only one door that's not
unlocked I believe and once I get in
there I'm gonna get the card or there's
gonna be a horrible monster no oh it's
both neither of what I thought it okay
don't like it I already don't like it I
do not like it at all all right what
have you got for me
horrible basement ah anything behind me
great
okay we're on no no this seems bad for
school down hmm
basement I don't like it at all
DNA I like that it's familiar ah rub it
all over my skin great hmm
where am I going I don't know and I like
the fact that it allows me to go
wherever I want to go first wish there
was some direction oh I don't like what
that implies I don't like what that
implies at all because that seems like
some kind of that that seems like some
kind of human trafficking bidding room
like I saw in taken No all right I'm
just gonna sit in the dark for a second
here because I got to recoup my
flashlight
now is the time to not think about
horribly scary things demons in the dark
the things that are hiding in your
closet the things that are under your
bed and the things that's standing
behind you right now
okay carrying on why is this is just the
worst thing mm oh good a questionable
stain this is awful
okay all right did I just get turned
around I did didn't I have it's got to
be a reason for all this but you know
that doesn't mean that the reason has to
be good but there has to be a reason
that they're uh oh boy oh I don't like
the way it spins Brett someone's onto us
5 4 3 7 ok 5 4 3 7 it is let me go let
me go
Oh the merry-go-round I guess we I mean
hell ok 5 4 3 7 5 3 4 7 5 4 3 7 that
sounds more right 5 4 3 7 ok so I don't
know where I'm gonna put that in but
that's probably important probably Oh I
opened it ok good Oh these beds are tiny
all right well that's uh someone's at
least in a good mood over there
all right I can't read it I made my bed
can I go home
this was directly below a school why why
oh why why and how how do you get away
get away - this [ __ ] makes no sense
give me that DNA I guess any witch's
eyes all right well that's flipping Oh
dad's locked oh yeah yeah this oh boy oh
this is where okay all right okay it
broke again there are a few connectors
in the broom cupboard up by the up hall
upstairs I get this fixed ASAP if you
don't want anyone getting in here how's
anybody gonna get in here because it's
broken now no one can get in here isn't
that how it works
[Music]
hmm so we tried to five nights at
freddys this [ __ ] oh that's bad move on
in five four three seven got it I don't
know what that uh
can't touch me
so we MC hammered himself into death
alright well that's uh that's that's
what oh no that's a message from this oh
that's yeah that's a just and fitting
end for that guy okay that makes more
sense I get it leave this school oh boy
great you know this is a wonderful
experience I'm so glad that I came to
this school you know knowledge is power
as they always say I think I don't think
I checked this last one
any last witch's eyes huh no all right
then well I'm outie then I'll see you
around the bend I think anyway it's
again disturbingly quiet there was a lot
of giggling and laughing going on before
and oddly I would rather have that than
the non reassuring silence of it all all
right then I went the wrong way I guess
I'll just leave see ya see ya dudes yeah
walking right out super weird
I don't know why as soon as I get
everything that I need everything turns
back to normal because that doesn't make
any sense at all why would that be the
case
oh hi how are you muscle man I should go
to hand well general it sounds like the
mayor and Taylor Walsh were good friends
she was also on the doctors list of
class 1 citizens to receive a piece of
Isabelle's card why is it so important
to divvy up these guards I don't
understand like what was the point
what's the benefit now whatever
oh no it's cliche Hospital time
boy alright then can I get a nice brain
juice and those those lovely vending
machines oh hello
alright well that's helpful got that
right away yep okay all right then well
alright time to methodically go have
time for a rousing game of fine the
jump-scare that's pretty much what this
does keep going until you find some
spook alicia's and oh boy you know I'm
gonna find some why is that door blocked
behind that requirement Oh Oh lovely oh
there's a really funkalicious violin
blare in the distance
they're either drunk or trying to spook
me I don't know which one is which
alrighty then better wash my hands
before I go in there hmm I don't like
all that that doesn't look good
okay just going on my way paying no mind
to anything that's happening over here
we're not going up those stairs and
definitely not oh oh good oh good do
they do ritualistic sacrifices in here -
I hope not alrighty then
cool thanks for the witch I really
appreciate that don't wanna know who you
dug that out of ah can't possibly get
over this cot alright I can't well all
right that's more reasonable I can't get
through that obviously anything in here
yep man it's almost like some someone
didn't want someone getting in oh this
guy didn't board it up stupid idiot
alright well got that I don't know what
oh there they are again the comforting
sounds of whatever the hell instrument
that is I think they're just squeezing a
cat that's all it is
hello oh alright sure
I'll go down oh oh it's the morgue oh
good oh great
wonderful great don't get up don't you
dare get up I don't want it none of it
okay Sarah please stop writing the
security passwords on scraps of paper
this is a blatant and serious security
risk we can't afford another incident
especially with the doctors more
frequent visits TWU who is the doctor oh
and here's a password oh boy
d7 for GZA to two on how am I gonna
remember that I don't know is it gonna
be written down somewhere nope I just
got to remember it all right Oh what oh
no no no oh come on
after I asked so nicely all right d7 for
GZA - to d7 for GZA - to d7 40ca - to t7
for g za - to d7 for g za - to d7 for g
za - to douglas 74 years old got zebra
ass 22 times
Douglas 74 years old got zebra ass 22
times Douglas
74 years old got zebra ass 22 times
Douglas whoo
okay sure hey don't slam doors in my
hospital
Douglas is that you tell me about those
zebra exploits Douglas 74 years old got
zebra ass 22 times all right okay I
guess that was Douglas on his way to
conquer another zebra Wow let's go
upstairs see what's going on up here
hello anyone want to walk slowly in
front of me that's the spookiest thing I
don't like that
Douglas 74 years old oh there's that cat
again man you need to stop squeezing
that cat that cat's just about had it
hello Oh what is this some kind of an
x-ray room
oh hello the password to the lift the
operating theater is fought beam destroy
this paper James should be at his post
at 12:05 the doctor will be in here from
12 we have one chance don't screw this
up do I got to remember that peen okay
Thompson had only penis three nights ago
Thompson had only penis for three nights
Thompson had only penis three nights
Douglas 74 years old got zebra ass 22
times Thompson had only penis three
nights
okay got it I don't know Thompson had
only penis three nights
okay got it okay all right whatever
don't say letters no stop that's not
what I need
[Music]
what is this counsel what are you trying
to heal people or hurt people why are
there anomalies huh what's going on the
anomalies somehow coincide with the
doctors arrival ah oh did I not need to
remember did I need to remember Thompson
a totally penis three nights and Daniel
David donk Donner Donson 74 years old
got zebra ass 22 times did I not need to
remember that okay well I unlocked it
but I remembered it but I remembered it
okay all right Oh fancy I probably
shouldn't be walking in here with a
flashlight which is metal all right
whatever it's probably not on except
that it is all right whatever
I'm out of here baby what's going on
over here huh is this open no I thought
I unlocked this I could have sworn I
could have sworn I thought I unlocked
that that seems like something that I
definitely did oh I don't wanna you
can't make me
here I go anyway all right well this is
fun okay hello how are you doing all
right on a scale of 1 to 10 how much
pain are you in right now
okay all right thank you what's around
the corner as I turn my back on you
oh no no no thank you I don't want any
no you can't make me I won't do it oh
okay
whoa whoa whoa ho ho ho hey she's lips
it's a miracle
so it's it's a good thing right
[Music]
okay
are you waiting on me
whoa whoa hey hey hey now stop it with
your floppy arms right now stop I don't
know if to do polish whatever I don't
know I see what I gotta do I just got a
run for it okay I can do that okay all
right then that's a rule a smash that
good okay all right okay
all right then oh wait hang on no how
about oh hi
all right well this is just a July 'full
dog I don't know why I needed to go in
there you know in fact I didn't oh
that's okay okay all right sure we're
gonna go with sure Oh No
what's with the wiring in this place
that constantly needs little wiring
boxes you'd think they'd just have wire
little s no it's not true at least I've
got this sweet delectable doctor's DNA
to make me feel all better huh okay more
I've got I've got to be getting close to
the cap right yeah oh of 50 I didn't
know it was of 50 I'm never gonna be I
thought it was of 25 oh it's 25 which
eyes it's not man it's gonna take
forever then all right here we go
oh hello
[Music]
before 6 p.m. and prepare them for
transport the enforcement will be
transporting yeah something tells me
that Taylor didn't make it much like the
other person and something tells me that
Taylor probably deserved not to make it
considering what seems to go on in these
horrible hell holes no no don't do it
no no no no no no no I hear that beeping
I'm just telling you straight up no no I
don't know what's going on with that but
I'm sure it can't be good
none of this good so why would I do what
I want to believe that it's good oh boy
I'm more Locker it's great oh god more
DNA even better oh boy piece of paper
and a junction box perfect hey so I know
we've been having trouble with the
security door on the third floor so I
got you this it should fix the problem
until the engineers can get it
permanently fixed why I don't know why
why are these magical engineering boxes
so it goddamn useful I don't like it
they're trying to replace a job I never
had as an engineer and it's [ __ ] oh
boy we're doing a great are these just
the hallways of collectibles is there
nothing actually here Oh yep it's the
hallways of collectibles okay got that
thank you okay Oh
uh okay all right sure yeah we all right
we're just gonna ignore that that never
happened
what's up here now I'm sure it's going
to be lovely and cheerful oh boy
God it's just a goddamn labyrinth and
what what the hell bro oh I see I see if
that makes sense okay that makes sense
oh okay what did I get and locks the
door to tailor Walsh's office is that
the one downstairs oh well someone did
someone tried to sanitize their hand way
too hard okay all right I'll be
downstairs in just a second I just got
to make sure I got everything on these
floors cuz there's so much to explore so
many fun times to be had in here okay
nothing all right
fare thee well then hello ah long
hallway of ominous intent I'm sure that
this is going to be something good for
me
and there's that beeping again and they
stop squeezing a cat they started just
beeping a horn hello hello hello nothing
a whole lot of nothing just long
hallways of [ __ ] that's all I get
play there's some garbage
all right I'll head back then not yet
hang on even more nothingness to explore
Oh God
more dinner perfect okay all right then
well that was all we needed from here
that was literally no point to any of
that it was just a wild goose chase and
instead of a goose I was just chasing my
own dick all right let's keep going okay
so I got the key so therefore I should
only need to go downstairs open that
office get the card and then I'm
boogieing on out of here right all right
hello don't mind me
anything what is this for unlocks the
door to the main security in the
hospital yeah okay all right okay all
right I'm out of here well I'm out here
for some reason it's not gonna let me go
through the front door I have to go
through some other [ __ ] door and
what was about what about David what
about David and David 74 years old got
zebra ass 22 times what about that what
about that code that seems like an
important code don't you guys think
that's an important code oh I'm on the
wrong floor that's why that's why I
don't need to be here all right down one
more sorry array skadoodle II yeah
ah ah that's tell time Oh perfect
great exactly what I needed
perfect perfect make it louder come on
man you can do this all right I know the
password anomaly detected okay that's Oh
Oh class one anomaly in the vicinity Oh
all right override Oh Oh can't run can't
run can't run oh that's weird
whoa hey hey hey hey hey no hey whoa hey
hey hey all right I'll just try to go I
guess whoa man it is a goddamn Raven
hear it it's awesome but what's
happening I kind of love it though
what's behind me well let me zoom in on
that oh boy all right please walk
towards the wall can I not okay it
doesn't want me to go all right
well all right oh it's coming to me
oh that's oh I'm being pulled towards oh
okay
that does make any sense at all oh boy
oh boy that's not good that's not good
that's some kind of light oh that's some
kind of horrible reality coming towards
me isn't it yeah boy I'm dead
I'm dead I didn't think it through I
can't even go back in there all I'm dead
okay well alright I accept my fate my
body is ready please oh it's a knot
Alton I hi
hello oh good oh I'm back here now
classification was which oh they're
probably pissed off that I've been
taking all their eyes oh oh is this a
crowbar for weapon oh it is you're gonna
make me whap something aren't you
you want me to waba licious something
don't you
okay all right you're gonna get whacked
hey hey where'd you go blimey no come on
I'm ready for the weapon oh yeah yeah oh
yeah you don't like that do you get get
some okay don't get some we're yet come
on oh there you are huh okay all right
hey
you're too fast oh no wow
alright then rather effective wouldn't
you thunk okay I'm on my way oh um okay
you know what maybe I don't need to go
in there I don't know why okay maybe I
gotta try to leave first or I don't know
why that guy was standing in there no I
just okay
I just I'm out all right okay it sounds
like there's a standoff between the
doctor and Walter young in the power
plant Young was one of the people the
doctor sent in a piece of Isabel
Miller's citizenship card I lied to the
power plant
Oh why does it look like a jail more
than a power plant with oh hi hello how
are you doing you alright alright see ya
I guess okay that's a little okay
alright cool friend tonight
Oh friend is gone okay I'm not sure if
I'm supposed to go that way first also I
don't know if I've been missing any
Easter eggs from not using my night
vision mode on my my flashlight here oh
well hello let's just carry on hey it's
the scene from five nights at freddy's
all right what do we got here
unlock the doors the power plant
maintenance doubles perfect no perfect
[Music]
which they won't oh I guess that's it
then
yeah just they won't they absolutely
won't why would they why would they want
to protect anybody that's trapped in
this hellhole why also is this a hell
why is it a regular thing that people
need to evacuate for these anomalies
it's probably the doctors fault just
just a
maybe you shouldn't trust this doctor
guy
maybe you shouldn't give the doctor guys
so much goddamn leeway all right
everybody in the Porta Potty oh they're
a witch I in that hole did someone [ __ ]
out of which I nope
would have been funny though no they've
been real hilarious okay I'm just gonna
take this DNA and then I know where it
wants me to go I got to go down into the
depths in that little cinder block of a
way sure make sense to me I guess here
we go
okay all right
that doesn't sound like the worst thing
in the world but it sounds pretty bad so
I'm gonna assume that it's pretty bad
and I'm gonna try to get out of here as
fast as I possibly okay well you don't
need to hey how's it going I'm charging
blindly in the darkness oh I thought
that was a person leaning over turns out
it was not ah give me that I don't know
why I'm getting you anyway all right
some kind of go great okay all right
then I'll just go the long way around
fine that means so much to you well
don't like the look of that I don't like
the look of this either well I can't get
in there so I'll take this bad look that
I don't like all right anybody hear more
DNA great DNA for what - because my
theory is my theory is that these
anomalous occurrences are a result of
just like the they're the result of the
doctors experimentation they have to be
this doctor is doing something that's
causing this town to go all Silent Hill
like there's no other explanation for it
I guess well I guess I'll just start
weighing doodling on random [ __ ] up
knowing minds hope this place doesn't
just blow up perfect thanks for the the
colorful light cues Oh
Wham oh my god that's oddly sexual all
right well that's that's good somehow
that's generating power sure all right
it looks fancy I'll take it
whatever oh do I gotta crawl in that
duct because I don't want to do that I
really don't want I don't know
okay it's not open it's fine
well that's closed you know what is this
oh hello you're new you know I'm
questioning a lot of things about this
weird blue is that blood
I hope it's blood wide if I hope it's
blood I have no idea at this point I
don't know what I'm hoping for
I'm open for another goddamn wish I
which I haven't seen in a while
well I can't go that way because there's
this impassable obstacle in front of me
and I can't possibly squeeze my girth
through that little gap
can I go under here is this something I
can do oh it's amazed Oh which I perfect
when you wish upon a star hmm oh I'm
here okay I'm on the other side now I
don't know what benefit that did me or
why I'm over here I don't even know what
I'm trying to do I know I'm trying to
get the power running again but it seems
like it's running on its own well
honestly what do I need to do Oh found
one valve is it the only valve I need I
don't know if there's two valves to be
had here
Oh - okay found - got him okay so I
think choose all I needed right so I got
these valves so I just put them on the
valve slots and then I can mosey on Gary
on with my life do whatever I want to do
live happily ever after all right
kachunk kachunk goals weird that do so
I'm important sounds like it there's
another valve over here that's right by
that little crawlspace and I'm pretty
sure that this is probably gonna open
that up and allow me to carry on forward
but then again I never really know
what's going on in this place
yeah come on oh wait no I need to do ah
it's perfect
ah open says me what I didn't mean to
open that much calm down there Tom thy
bull drafty tits okay all right is there
blood in here semen don't like that okay
well this is is a nice there's a nice
shot beautiful all right oh okay oh no
this is the opposite of what's good all
right sure come on whatever is gonna pop
out of me to do it already huh I'm
zoomed in I'm ready I'm sorry I'm not
ready oh boy
yeah Omar oh good more more duct work to
crawl through oh boy I'm so happy about
oh great
it's more it's more everybody Oh your
wishes came true
it's done alright okay is that it Oh Oh
which is I and a dead body over there
but I'm not gonna worry about that right
now
I need to collect my eyeballs hmm
hello do you have a piece of a card cuz
that's kind of what I need it's kind of
what I came here for so if you could
just give me that I'd be extremely happy
oh you have a wrench well I'm gonna have
to pick up where you wore all right all
right I'm gonna have to pick up where
you left off I guess nope no I'm not
apparently I'm not there I am I've got
it now did you do this all these body
Hey stop it stop just stop get out of
here man what all right then well
alrighty then
I'm gonna assume that that guy managed
to whomp down about a half a dozen of
those and that last one was the one that
survived which means that he's kind of a
badass he did pretty good there unlocks
all the doors to the power plant
building that would have been very
useful to get way way way way way
earlier in the game but I'll take what I
can and I'm assuming I've still got this
monkey wrench because I need to whomp it
someone else is that well I'm reading
into this probably alright let's see
what's in here
coach uncles all right okay
leave the power plant well easy Sal huh
what's happening though escape that's
different than leaving okay all right
are you someone in high heels over there
then that spells danger in my book oh
okay all right let's rip do evils I see
I'm Audi baby I don't even need to fight
you do I get stuck I'm so tall my head
hit the ceiling for some reason Oh
Trevor I'm isn't it probably let's take
a gander back no I can't I just can
block all right whatever I'm out of here
making it making my way downtown walking
fast faces pass into homebound
oh that's the anomaly radio I forgot
about forget that was even a thing
hi okay it's clear that Isabelle Miller
was wrongly sent to Hanwell jail during
the final moments of the council she has
a piece of her card I might also be able
to find out more about what happened
here Oh
ah you know now you know wait a minute
wait a minute
wait a minute wait this is from I've
seen this before
I've legitimately seen this before
no I've seen this that's right I need a
food as soon as possible two four six
zero one I've played welcome to Han well
I did not connect those dots I
completely forgot about that this is the
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I completely
forgot about that
what the heck II hack alright oh no oh
no we say it isn't so not our doctor
seems like we might be getting some
conflicting inquiries about the whole
status of who's in charge here but uh
you know okay all right then oh yeah oh
yeah I totally remember it God how long
ago did I play it - it came a bit
forever ago but it was a good bit ago
and I totally forgot about this yeah the
three doors yeah that doesn't work oh I
don't know if I should be excited about
this or not but I bet they're gonna have
fresh spooks for me oh oh no no calls
for me today or no calls today
alright then doesn't look good okay what
do you got
oh yeah the food Wow
alright Joe the phone broke I need to
get to the warden about why
down stuck your L all this [ __ ] falling
apart when the suits upstairs get a
brand new office plus these guys are
getting impatient half of the map and he
haven't haven't even had a trial I'm
leaving early that's right
okay all right I can't remember if that
was the same as before but okay
all right good stuff all around good
stuff good stuff glad we're here it's
not another electrical box okay all
right
someone blew the doors off of this
[ __ ] here all right
it's carry on all right
and the cell block oh oh okay big box
Barry what did you do oh hi oh hi hello
hi how are you oh your staple shuts
mouth man oh I am brute okay
hi brutes how are you doing brute broody
boy you're looking good
don't mind me one of these somehow these
are all gonna open I know I know that I
know that's gonna happen oh all righty
then
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh there's a lot of
DNA in these jail cells well how do I
get to it that's the question on my mind
and also how much more DNA to I possibly
need oh wow that wow that's a lot of
blinder great okay cool so one behind me
no not today not this time okay all
right okay all right whoo cool ooh
another long hallway that looks like a
death great let me first see what's down
this hallway before I go committing
without nothing oh hi
okay all right then I can't see you the
bars are in the way looking good good
look at you okay you know what I'll just
back away slowly apparently I'm not
supposed to go there
that seems like a bad idea all right the
decision has been made for me I will be
going down this hallway all right great
hate it I already hate it I hate it okay
I hate it Oh new cellblock same
cellblock
new all same different it's different
okay
I'm sorry this has to be the way we
sever our friendship but my work is
forward to individual okay and so you
killed him about it
for your oh so important work oh oh
sorry
oh hi hello Oh your Miller oh okay
are you dead in there just taking a nap
there's some bad stuff happening but I
mean if brutes alive then I suppose
can't all be bad I don't like this my
flashlights been on too long let me just
turn it off for a bit okay we're just
gonna sit nothing bad can happen to us
if we just sit in the darkness all by
ourselves okay now no flashlights still
bad it's just supposed to be like that
all right well I hate it I unarguably
hate it oh it's bad
how can I go through this way now is it
gonna be open now no still better ok
still bad you know what's still bad all
right you know it's still bad don't turn
it off okay so what do I do
I didn't get what I needed I don't think
I gotta find access to that cell so I
got to open up all the cell blocks
probably Oh for [ __ ] sake for [ __ ]
sake I didn't see that okay all right
well going back ah there they are
perfect okay alright glad we cleared
that up Isabel don't worry I'm coming
for your citizenship card for some
reason yeah alright it's god I can't
believe I miss those all right be right
back unless something happens all right
let me see this key almost got it
unlocks a control room in the jail yeah
and I'm pretty sure it's right up these
stairs and it's that oh whoa low bridge
I'm pretty sure it's this one right to
the left here and I'm pretty sure that
I'm not gonna like this okay all right
remember in the event of a riot panic
scream run as fast as you can
alrighty then alright everybody's free
everybody's free oh great breathe
happy fruitmeier brute real mild or a
brute you have fun I'll come find you in
a bit brute I'll come find you in a bit
don't worry about it
Dora brutes brutes brutes going ok
brutes leaving all right so it shouldn't
be too bad right it shouldn't be too bad
probably oh this is open now time for
intro oh you're just gonna watch me
shower
oh you perverts question mark is this
like extra perversion or is is this okay
okay well I just
lalalalalala sing it in the shower all
badoo badoo badoo badoo boop well this
bad okay
can I come out now oh I don't like it oh
hi oh I thought I was alone in here okay
okay okay good god that's horrible
oh well how are you finding your shower
may I scrub your back all right then
that's awful oh this is the worst thing
okay ah more yes okay excellent Oh Paul
showers are now full great perfect okay
Oh
that's pretty good I'm not gonna lie
that was that was pretty good
that was pretty good I'm not gonna lie I
wouldn't lie to you that was pretty good
all right let me go around and collect
all the DNA samples all right and let me
get the which I first and Isabella you
did oh oh you oh you oh you're extremely
oh you're very dead all right then I
believe that no no shut up no I don't
know I don't I don't I don't need it I
got that all right I'm gonna leave the
jail now sorry I would have listened to
the rest of it again but I just didn't
feel like it I'm sorry I'm just checking
for any last DNA there's one more again
don't know why I needed but you know
there it is
should I leave through the yard that's
where I went in the demo so I can only
assume that maybe you wants me to go
that way because brute went that way
and Ebru one that way I'm gonna go that
way because if there's someone I trust
in this hellhole its brute maybe
oh why is the music kicking up you don't
need to do that
oh yeah it's open all right okay okay
all right baby baby oh I remember this
oh yeah please tell me that brood is
just walking around the yard oh oh
there's nothing oh oh it's a whole lot
of nothing all right then why did I come
here
hmm he's not even a witch I in sight
all right well it was a whole lot that
thing then okay I'm assuming
everything's fine and I just got to go
out the front door that seems like
something that's true all right
I'm gonna attempt to leave at the front
door
nothing seems to be stopping me so just
fine oh oh okay well don't tell me I
gotta go running all the way back oh no
okay well that is a thing now
what do i oh that's oh well this isn't
good at all
oh this is the opposite of good okay
anything new happening over here
lockdown roaming does it does that mean
oh oh oh oh oh okay all right then
that's not good room please after all
we've been through together brute are
you still running after me boy Wow okay
brute is very quietly skip stepping his
way towards me I guess I'll go to the
yard I suppose I don't know I think I
got to loop them around I got to give
him the old loop-d-loop a runaround
you're their brute you their brute oh
he's there alright okay alright just
gonna give you a nice loop-d-loop
I didn't know brew was smart enough
finish yet the lockdown eat their fruit
I don't know I don't like that I don't
like the way it's just pure darkness
that bright root stop twice if you're
their brute oh boy up we go assuming
brute is directly behind me and here we
go oh that only opens one way [ __ ]
alright there we go we're good we're
good we're good we're good we're good
and I'm assuming we're outie okay oh
that's it that's weird
oh well finally the council the triple
goes a bright green at the swipe of
Miller's card oh that's what I'm a head
I can see the gates the motors roar as
they open allowing me in sure oh great
we're gonna finally get to the
quote-unquote bottom of all this
apparently boy no blood here
seems like they're doing a good job
thank you okay
ooh I don't have the password I don't
know it but I'm gonna remove okay oh
you're very [ __ ]
oh no that's not good whoop okay it's
all motion sensors I see I understand I
get you hmm
okay ah what the hell did I do all right
wrong and right here we go winner winner
chicken dinner indeed okay okay okay
what happened little wood wise little
win so little that you didn't even to
capitalize the name a little wood no no
look at all this wiring it's gonna go
wrong
also these TVs TVs on every single wall
of the hall a lockdown City what does
that even mean that it's a lockdown city
is this anomaly thing happening all over
the world or is it only happening
Hanwell also this place is way too nice
I don't like it it's way too nice and
there's not a drop of blood anywhere
having a natural security card level one
acquired great okay what does that mean
what do I get for that what kind of
special prize you're gonna give me oh no
I can't squeeze go this way then I'd
like to think these are windows but they
seem to just be giant TVs oh great well
I got a security card so that's gonna do
goodly for me I think I don't know do I
need to swipe it again in the security
panel surveillance maybe oh no I just
came from there so this has got to give
me over to the deployment area
yeah I would have thought that there
would have been some kind of security
guards or something like that people
would come kind of anti anomaly done if
I can whack them with a crowbar and
assume that generally you could yeah Wow
good advice that you should have been
saying a while ago can I have one of
these guns please I'm assuming these are
gun lockers and that they're used in the
occurrence of anomalies which I'm cursin
currently fighting hello hello okay oh
all right then
you stay true to you what is this Oh
password discovered oh god that's a long
one Aleut aha Logano we sinned 12 okay
I'm not even going to come up with
analogy I was gonna come up with analogy
if it was short enough but that is way
too goddamn long and I don't all right
fine I'll do it
[ __ ] what is it I can't even read what
it says i l w th t holla
igano we sinned 12 all right I love when
those happy awesome little ladies all
agonizingly gallop around Newton Oh
what evil sinners I interpret now 12:12
shut up shut up it doesn't make any
goddamn shot up shut up don't quote me
on that those stupid shut up
I got a password point user one unlocked
can I get in security no okay can I go
through here now oh well this is awfully
nice
oh never mind it's too nice don't like
it okay I'll just gonna skedaddle all
righty then I don't know what this place
is and I don't know why it's here but I
don't like it well I would but all the
mirrors happen to be broken they were
all broken everywhere every single one
that I found was all broked all right
was this administrative you have a milot
mirror anybody have a mirror oh god all
monitors no mirrors okay all right then
guess I'll just imagine what I look like
oh I don't know the code for that Miller
what did Miller even do was Miller like
some kind of important person in this
what kind of recreation are you doing
are you trying to get a football team
for Hanwell hand weld University what
are you trying to what are you trying to
do
because if there's one more there's a
server room back there too oh there's a
piece of paper over here
oh yeah
oh I got a password oh no it's the same
one okay I don't need to come away bingo
how can you keep forgetting it's pretty
easy as long as you know the first four
numbers of the top two times table I'll
give you a clue the first ones too ha ha
al 2 4 6 8 is that it
the 2 4 6 8 I don't know whatever two
four six eight who do we appreciate me
me I got an engineering clearance my
dream has finally come true alright
let's go to the server room oh it's all
futuristic and high-tech I love it
hey why is the doctor just throwing his
DNA absolutely everywhere he possibly
can all right you know what I got it
it's great nice servers I don't know why
I went through there mm nice Locker like
the one that moves in the school did I
need to go to the server room for any
reason did I need to do anything
does anybody have a mirror still looking
at still waiting on that mirror all
right has anyone else wondered why we
just call him the doctor who even is he
Doctor Who oh I got a password no I
don't know the password I just got a
password I did though this is weird okay
oh wow science there's obviously a lot
of science that's been happening here
Wow DNA very science II okay but also
what am I looking for here man
everything's in a state of disarray but
there again not a drop of blood and I'm
sure that's intentional because they
have been just throwing blood around
every single other location that I've
been do so there's got to be a reason
there is no blood it's too clean and I
can't imagine that everybody got away
from it whatever it was
oh boy
Engineering finally I can get to my
dream place what was what okay all right
is that good or bad I don't imagine that
he's dangerous by himself huh okay all
right again doesn't make any sense how
I'm able to wander around everywhere of
everything's so dangerous what exactly
is the danger Oh
all right danger over there no
apparently not they're just testing
doors great
the ultimate security doors and let me
see what's over here social engineering
what does that even mean what what are
you socially engineer izing that doesn't
make any sense I don't get it I don't
understand oh this is way above my pay
grade because I never finished
engineering school I just don't
understand oh this is green why is it so
green okay and we're back all right
I got a password boink all right oh do I
need oh this is what that password was
for oh I see so technically I do have
everything then what did I get from that
safe still don't like that Oh
[Music]
uh-oh you can't get through that okay
oh very dead okay I should get out of
the way that huh well this is problem oh
oh oh okay almost died all right I see I
see I'm going not very secure I think oh
yeah I guess oh okay I made it wow you
know your security system kind of sucks
I mean I know I saw it and resin and
evil but it worked way better then than
it did here man all right I barely even
came close to dying ah surely okay all
right then I don't know what that means
and I don't know what I am I'm trying to
find a mirror but I just don't
understand I don't understand any
[Music]
okay well that's rude I haven't even met
you you've only been looking and talking
to me I haven't even seen you where are
you at huh what's going on here this
[ __ ] mezes is why I'm collecting all
the DNA mayor's security guard acquired
great okay oh so am i a clone of the
doctor I don't understand that at all or
why but okay you know what all right
I think that's a okay oh hi hello okay
hi how you doing how you doing mayor how
you doing let me get a good look at you
okay all right well I guess I should go
meet him then huh didn't you do you have
a mirror like a pocket mirror in your
handbag or something I don't know okay
all right then
so yeah I'll just go meet the doctor
then I guess doc you here is the doctor
in his office because this does say
doctor over here and I'm only assuming
that you know that's a thing that I need
to do
surely all right anyway
okay office dr. doc doc you in here all
right
in another password whoo see this did
manage to maintain 99% of my DNA within
c3 unfortunately he died within a week
with spirit or a failure
no matter the infusion of anomalous DNA
with my own negates the need for a
successor
ah okay all right anomalous DNA how's
how's Eddie who's that a thing what do
you mean anomalous DNA kind of anomalous
DNA are you working with why does it not
leave an AB DNA uh-huh hello doc are you
in here are you anom alized okay all
right then um I don't know the password
why don't I know the password I don't
even know the code to this thing well
[ __ ] nope not always an axe huh all
righty then I don't know where I'm going
Oh oh that is subtle oh that is very
subtle oh is that a - I think it's - 296
Oh
that took a while to find but I think I
got it all right - nine 600 password Oh
ll FG and opie look Larry forget gonads
no one oops
all right I was always better with
numbers okay I got it
oh oh oh no oh oh oh that's that that's
not good that's not good the mayor
doesn't look so healthy um all right did
I do that by deactivating Glazer Gator
did that already happen and I'm just
kind of an [ __ ] but you know I guess
it doesn't matter no matter what happens
I'm gonna get through there I'm gonna
get the finals gonna be hunky-dory you
still here guys oh good Oh yep oh good
okay all right closure indeed good god
it's like you just exploded into blood
all right well whatever I got the last
password I suppose I should feel worse
about that but for some reason I do not
this is carry on to see what's at the
end here all right hello ah oh yes very
very fancy oh no there's another door
that I gotta get through how can there
be a higher echelon of security than
what we just saw oh ah I see okay VI VIP
refectory what does that even mean
Entertainment genetics oh no denied okay
containment okay what is with these
walls what's the point of any of this
are the flickering lights by design
biology okay sure yeah oh good we can go
in biology I'm sure this is where all my
DNA will come into play all right okay
that is weird I know that I have no idea
what I'm looking at okay oh nice music
I'm
kind of aliens I'm assuming great great
glad we're dealing with aliens let's
probably the way back out this bride is
some other know well that don't look
good I probably shouldn't walk directly
into that yep okay I was right can't
walk directly into it okay yeah what do
we have here no passwords is another
security terminal well I don't have the
answer now do i oh hello oh you don't
look so good oh you don't look good at
all oh well what is wrong with you
you're like some kind of SCP in this
place is containing you probably more
close to the truth than I thought it
would be okay I'm gonna go deactivate
whatever security systems probably
unleash you point Oh another bow that
was just another password okay I've got
two passwords now don't know what the
hell I'm gonna do with those but okay
he's alright mainframe nope not there
okay maybe I got both the passwords that
probably be pretty nice I don't know if
it's gonna be that easy
maybe nope I don't know the password
well how am I gonna be able to get into
any of these other ones but I thought
well where does it I got two passwords
didn't maybe I did oh hello
Oh genetics clearance great I didn't
even notice that that was hard to find
it seems to be a common theme in this
last level oh whoa hey whoa why oh oh
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you
oh my god why is that necessary holy
[ __ ] okay oh I see Chism's
you bout cut my liver out good thing I
got all this doctor DNA and so oh I
don't look good
alright oh that's not good that's not
good how j'son's okay I'm gonna go now
nope not gonna make it am i ah
what the [ __ ] where is it gonna put
me back
oh good here ya it knows that how all
right fine then
ow okay I found my path I found my path
ow
okay al we Oh oh it's still coming all
right I gotta get into the genetics I'm
going for it duh
why why why security system now was the
doctor oh there's the blood finally I'm
so happy er that I found the place where
all the blood is great good what is this
I don't know all right
containment clearance that's nice
what's in containment that I could
possibly want to know about because that
sounds bad okay not going in there
Jason's alright fine
oh the squealing is happening again okay
nevermind alright containment I see
alright oh oh this is fine
[Music]
nope okay oh yes oh hi hello I'm sorry
you know what some does me I shouldn't
be in here it's like some come up kind
of other bidding room hello No okay whoa
what the [ __ ] hey [ __ ] you man I got
the password [ __ ] you
Jason's dead actually scared the bejesus
out of me I only have so many positions
left good golly stop being a dick
all right well Oh [ __ ] okay we made
it security system lockdown is it still
is it so bad okay it's fine still by me
okay open please can you deal with the
thing behind me okay good okay well that
seems weird and dictatorial what is this
what is this excuse me I know that was
incredibly important oh good a ranch oh
no oh oh that's not good that's what you
would call not good hah doc huh oh well
no not that one well okay not that one
either
oh boy huh
oh one more DNA I'm gonna be pissed if
I've missed one sample of that dr. sweet
DNA but I guess that explained the whole
99 percent thing huh I'm just not good
enough
am i dad I never lived up to your
measurement dad can I get through here
or no oh well our apparel
okay okay apparently I can I didn't know
I had the passwords doc
doc there's a lot of rich till the
doctor okay you know you know I don't
put hey oh I see
ah that's supposed to help me okay can I
give you oh no no really I don't really
care about hand well all I know is that
things are going weird well know where
you are but okay
where'd you go oh hey Doc oh hi how you
doing can I help you oh all righty then
I don't know what that was supposed to
do it's not very intimidating how about
a good old-fashioned wrench me know if I
had a gun I feel like this would be a
lot easier whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa can
I turn on the laser trap jgomes
no not really
oh ha ha get rekt ow my blood I needed
that bleiben okay you can have it
am i hitting you I'm right up on whoa
okay
Oh ow maybe oh oh oh no no no no no I'm
getting bounced around like a sock
puppet
okay well I'm dead all right well
now to fight this guy I don't know what
the hell I'm doing all right whatever
pick up a ranch hello
come on come at me come at me
nah-nah-nah-nah whap whap is how Oh what
the [ __ ]
oh god it's one of you ah no oh please
don't no I don't want it there we go I
think I just need to get enough laps on
them directly to you oh that's not good
[ __ ] stop stop stop stop Scott game
and I thought I'd turned on the lasers
uh [ __ ] whatever no come on
oh [ __ ] bags that's right get down okay
let me turn this on whoa whoa whoa
what's the [ __ ] why do you keep getting
but you get to keep bypassing my
[ __ ] there we go
[ __ ] - you out ah come on you're so
annoying stop you're annoying god you're
so annoying okay I'm gonna get you
no I don't have a goddamn wrench are you
[ __ ] with me
oh there's no wrenches up here oh god
damn it okay well okay all right
wonderful all right well I can't do
anything until I get a [ __ ] alright
here we go
yes oh not you just Oh stop bouncing me
oh you are so annoying
oh really [ __ ] [ __ ] you know oh my
god oh my god this is the most annoying
thing I've ever done right okay this is
great yeah this is wonderful thank you
for this okay yeah it's bounced me
around yeah bouncing me around when I
can't even [ __ ] jump I've I don't
have a weapon no come on I don't have a
weapon I can't move
god dammit I I can't [ __ ] move god
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] kidding me
this is the worst get the [ __ ] out of my
way are you kidding me
wait oh he's dead oh good [ __ ] you good
God
gah my god that was [ __ ] impossible
such a weird move for a game to decide
to suddenly be a combat game cuz I mean
it was like very no way I mean there was
combat but there was so little huh okay
I guess good ah huh I mean that's my
only criticism about the game is the
ending what a weird [ __ ] ending but
that is the counsel of Han well made by
a Nathan seed house 3d art by Nile voice
music by James LC that was good
it had its flaws it was a bit stiff it
was a bit rough around the edges but
even so that was a fun adventure I'm
glad I was able to play it all in one go
and I'm glad that you guys were able to
see it all the same thank you everybody
that watched this let me know what you
think of this game down in the comments
below there aren't too many indie horror
games being made these days so it's
always good to see something special
come out of the indie development
community and I always want to celebrate
when they're made it did have its flaws
it did but it also had a lot of really
cool moments a lot of scary moments and
it was good to see progress happen from
the last time I played the demo of this
to now so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]